and finally new rule democrats have to
stop talking about
packing the supreme court because it's
already packed
with catholics roberts
thomas alito kavanaugh sotomayor and
gorsuch
who i count as catholic because he was
raised catholic and is now episcopalian
which is just a catholic
who flunked latin
and once mitch mcconnell and company are
done fedexing amy coney barrett to the
bench
seven of the nine justices will be
catholic and look i have nothing against
catholics except my entire upbringing
but they are only 20 of the population
if seven out of nine
justices were jews or muslims or
buddhists
would that be okay and if faith is this
super important element of life as
barrett and her republican supporters
say it is shouldn't we have a healthier
balance on our highest court
the fastest growing denomination in
america is nuns
no not that kind i'm talking about
atheists agnostics and people who when
asked what their religion is say
none
thanks we are 26
of the country not anyone here but of
the country
where's our voice on the supreme court
an atheist thank you it's all right i
know they're out there i know where you
are my people
[ __ ] them we're just us
and atheists actually make better judges
because we don't have to work to
separate church and state we're not torn
between
rational decision making and what it
says in the old book of jewish fairy
tales
in 2006 barrett told a graduating class
of law students
keep in mind that your legal career is
but a means to an
end that end is building the kingdom of
god
no it's not that's not the point of a
legal career
a new pundits earnestly debating whether
she will vote to overturn
roe versus wade of course she will she's
been groomed since
birth to overturn roe versus wade she's
like the terminator
a robot programmed to fulfill one task
except she wasn't sent from the future
she was sent from the past
because here's the truth about catholics
in america there's two types
scary and not scary
the vast majority not scary not
doctrinaire
in fact they're famous for ignoring
everything the pope tells them not to do
they divorce they use contraception they
have premarital sex they have anal sex
sometimes all in one night
but there's another strain of uber
conservative catholics who have an
agenda
an enormous and growing influence to
achieve it and it's really about pining
for a return to the middle ages
when the church was the state the
attorney general
is one of these people so as the
federalist society
responsible for putting five justices on
the court
the knights of malta and opus dei whose
members wear a little spiked chain
around their
thigh all day to remind them of you
you-know-who
now i know what to get mel gibson for
christmas
these old-school catholics they play the
long game
amy barrett has been on their radar
since forever because she was raised in
an extremist catholic community called
people of praise
where a husband's responsibilities
included correcting his wife
should she stray from the proper path
uh-huh and where women were called
handmaids yeah these are the folks who
make jehovah's witnesses go
shh don't answer the door
they speak in tongues otherwise known as
babbling
isn't that something called
kapoke
that wasn't them doing it but that's
what it is and they do it too and now
it's on the court
it's not wrong to call out nuts when
[ __ ] is nuts
oh thank you
i knew i'd get to hear with that [ __ ]
last year pope benedict the spare parts
pope
the first pope to ever collect a pension
he wrote a letter for the world where he
decried the loss of morality beginning
in the 1960s he wrote
this is his words standards regarding
sexuality collapsed entirely
that is why sex films were no longer
allowed on airplanes
because violence would break out among
the small community of passengers
okay one what airline are you flying
and two what the [ __ ]
yeah i think we all remember those days
in air travel when there was more leg
room and that also show
porn on the flight until you got so
horny you'd punch the guy in 32
b
bennett benedict also wrote
his words that quote because of the
revolution of 68 whatever the [ __ ] that
was
pedophilia was then diagnosed as allowed
and appropriate
really is that what the who meant by the
kids are all right
you know before anyone at the vatican
starts calling anyone else a pedophile
you might want to check the color of
your kettle because
we traced the call and it's coming from
inside the belfry
amy barrett said this week she had no
strong feelings about
climate change but is very concerned
about
large belt buckles
chuck schumer said democrats won't make
barrett's religion an issue
but they should because being nuts is
relevant
you